how do you get a film financed and how
do you get distribution for a film so
that's the that's the main thing
there's no clean-cut way to do either of
those things it's a it's you know
sometimes certain things work and
sometimes they don't I had seen a film
that I was not impressed with and it
inspired me to do anything it was the
idea like don't let perfect be the enemy
of good so you called up James I'm like
I'm pulling the trigger on this I've got
a bunch of investors who put money into
other films before my thought was let's
jam it out and get it done
so James had a distributor in front of
his approaching a distributor in advance
is something that really helps
especially for this film what I did is I
had my movie pernicious which is coming
out in theaters soon that all the
distributors saw when I was playing
festivals and they made bids on it and
the distributor's that we didn't end up
selling the film to I approached and
said hey you know they put in an offer
for it and I said hey if I made a film
in the same genre would you buy it and
they said yes and so they pre bought the
film and so these films were pre-sold
before they were made it was very easy
to finance them based off of they were
already sold before they were made so
it's like hey one once the film is
delivered you get X amount of dollars
from the distributor it's very easy to
say hey can you finance this because I'm
literally basically borrowing money from
him for like a little bit of time and
then it comes in he said specifically
what he's looking for as opposed to
making up a movie they like this is my
passion project it was here's the
distributor Awards they basically said
as long as I'm writing and directing
which on one eye and then I swung it as
a tube film deal that I would write both
with his AK exact with direct one and I
would direct one and then they said that
it had to be like ghost house type stuff
so like you know Jean were films with a
supernatural element that's that's
what's big right now for for genre so it
was haunted house film the ghost girl
and inside that niche we could do
whatever we wanted so we came up with
about two
different concepts pitch to him he chose
which ones he liked and then we wrote
them and we literally wrote them over
Christmas my girlfriend is very very
kind and understanding so over Christmas
we were locked in our offices sleeping
they're writing 17 hours a day jamming
it out and we got we wrote restoration
in five days for the first draft and
then Bethenny we wrote in seven days and
then we both went our separate ways to
do our polishes on each so I would
directed restoration he was gonna direct
Bethenny so I polished restoration he
paused Bethenny so once we had that we
already had the distribution I talked to
my investors and at this budget we had a
good mg minimum guarantee so it wasn't
that much of a risk financially it was a
real thing to move forward with so we
did and it's you know it's micro-budget
films it's hard it's really hard but we
have fantastic prose and wonderful
people that were working with and then
we have begged for every favor we could
get
so we then clued up cast up and locked
it down and started shooting and we did
them back-to-back so we did we're doing
six day weeks my restoration was 14
shooting days six day weeks and three
days down and then started better verse
fourteen cheesiness